[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich glaube, das wird das kürzeste Video,
was ich jemals auf diesem Kanal hochgeladen habe.
Es gibt jetzt nämlich ein
blitzschnelles Rezept für ein Fruchteis,
was ihr wirklich sofort zubereiten könnt.
Superlecker!
Und vor allem für mich als Mama ist immer ganz wichtig,
im Sommer wollen die Kinder oft Eis essen.
Und da kommt es natürlich auch vor,
dass sie jeden Tag Eis essen wollen
und vielleicht auch zweimal am Tag.
Und das finde ich auch völlig okay,
solange man es nicht übertreibt.
Und daher habe ich mir es wirklich angewöhnt,
das Eis auch selber zu machen,
weil ich den Zuckergehalt bestimmen kann.
Ich kann bestimmen,
ob ich überhaupt Industriezucker verwende oder nicht.
Und ich kann einfach bestimmen,
was drinnen ist.
Dieses Eis
– das ist jetzt ein Fruchteis –
werde ich zubereiten.
Ihr könnt es auch super vegan vorbereiten.
Und ihr braucht wirklich nur vier Zutaten
und fünf Minuten eurer Lebenszeit.
Und es ist Eis komplett ohne Industriezucker.
Ich verwende dafür
300 Gramm gefrorene Früchte,
– da habe ich einfach eine schön bunte Mischung –
zwei reife Bananen zum Süßen,
100 Gramm Joghurt
und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Vanilleextrakt ist natürlich nur optional.
Ihr könnt auch ein bisschen Zitronenabrieb dazu geben.
Aber es verfeinert einfach das Ganze
und hebt so ein bisschen noch mal den Geschmack.
Ich habe hier einfach alle Reste an Früchten genommen,
die ich so gefunden habe,
Blaubeeren, Himbeeren,
Kirschen.
Erdbeeren gehen auch ganz gut.
Und ich habe hier zwei fleißige Helferinnen,
die heute das Eis zubereiten werden.
Samira und Greta!
Hallo, ihr zwei Süßen!
Freut ihr euch schon auf das Eis?
>> SAMIRA & GRETA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Super!
Also alles, was wir brauchen, ist im Prinzip
ein Mixer oder einen Stabmixer.
Kommt ihr da hoch, Mädels?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, also ich...
>> SALLY: Geht, oder?
Guckt mal. Ihr könnt mal die Bananen
schon mal schälen und reingeben.
Wie früher, nicht?
Wie in deinem alten Video.
Ja, so geht es natürlich auch.
Quatschkopf!
>> SAMIRA: Rein.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Soll ich Vanilleextrakt auch schon reinmachen?
Und die Bananen, die dürfen wirklich schön süß und reif sein,
also gerne außen auch schon braun gefleckt.
Was ich auch immer ganz gerne mache, ist,
dass ich Bananen, wenn sie schon überreif sind,
einfach schäle und einfriere.
Dann habe ich praktisch da
auch schon mal die kalte Komponente.
So. Der Joghurt darf auch rein.
Schön auskratzen.
Und bei den Beeren einfach benutzen, was euch schmeckt.
Ob ihr jetzt Erdbeereis wollt, Himbeereis,
Kirscheis, Aprikoseneis,
ist völlig egal.
Oder Mango!
Oh, Mangoeis! Mmh!
>> SAMIRA: Mangoeis haben wir da.
>> SALLY: Und wenn...
Ja, stimmt. Das habe ich gekauft.
Und wenn ihr praktisch sagt,
ich habe keine gefrorenen Früchte,
nehmt ihr frische Früchte, friert sie ein, bis sie gefroren sind,
und könnt dann das Eis zubereiten.
Sodele.
Greta, wenn du möchtest.
Kommst du dran oder soll ich dir helfen?
Huch!
Komm, ich helfe dir.
>> GRETA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das ist echt ein bisschen hoch für euch, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Mit der Kenwood-Maschine.
>> SALLY: So. Und jetzt mixen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt ist das Eis schon fertig.
Je nachdem, welche Früchte ihr verwendet,
solltet ihr natürlich eine Banane mehr oder weniger nehmen.
Also Erdbeeren sind eigentlich immer schön süß.
Himbeeren sind eher sauer
und Kirschen auch.
Das heißt, wir probieren einfach
und verfeinern nach eurem Geschmack
das Eis einfach weiter.
Und ich habe jetzt hier keine gefrorenen Bananen benutzt.
Das heißt, das Eis ist etwas softer.
Ich könnte es jetzt noch mal kurz
für eine Stunde einfrieren.
Wenn ihr gefrorene Bananen habt,
könnt ihr es auch wirklich sofort essen.
Aber so ist es so eher wie so ein Softeis, nicht?
Auch gut.
>> SAMIRA: Wir müssen eben jetzt das Eis bewerten.
>> SALLY: Okay, bewertet mal das Eis.
Ich hole solang eine Schüssel.
Kriege ich eure Punktzahl?
>> SAMIRA: Warte.
1 bis 10 Punkte.
Beide 10.
>> GRETA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja!
Ja!
Yay, der Goldene Buzzer!
Ich habe den Goldenen Buzzer.
Ich hatte jetzt hier diese Schüssel auch bereits im Gefrierfach.
Das heißt, die ist auch schön kalt.
Also entweder serviert ihr es jetzt sofort
aus Bechern, aus Gläsern oder wie auch immer,
die Kinder und Erwachsenen können sofort essen
oder ihr friert es noch mal kurz ein,
damit es einfach eine etwas festere Konsistenz bekommt.
Ich würde sagen, wir frieren es ein.
Dann können wir euch so Kugeln machen.
>> SAMIRA: Oh!
>> SALLY: Oh, hoppla!
Habe ich da gekleckert?
>> SAMIRA: Hm!
Hast du.
>> SALLY: Ja. Wollt ihr es gleich aus so Waffeln?
>> SAMIRA: Oh ja!
>> GRETA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Vielleicht diese Miniwaffeln.
Die haben wir vielleicht drüben,
weil, ich glaube, Eis...
>> SAMIRA: Schoko-Miniwaffeln!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Weil, ich glaube, Eiswaffeln habe ich keine mehr.
Also ich friere es ein
und dann wird bei uns schon Eis gegessen.
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht.
Sollen wir jetzt das Video schon beenden?
Weil es ist eigentlich fertig.
Mh.
Wir sehen uns gleich noch mal.
Hier. Wollt ihr abschlecken?
Ach, nicht alleine!
Mit deiner Freundin!
Aha!
Kaum gibt es Eis, wer kommt angerannt?
Hallo!
>> SAMIRA: Ela!
Kommt!
>> SALLY: Oh, du süße Maus!
Hi, Schatzi!
Komm mal her!
>> ELA: Mama, hier war gerade so ein Ding.
Aber das hat gar nicht wehgetan.
>> SALLY: Hallo?
Ich bin jetzt etwas neidisch auf Samiras schöne Umarmung.
Kriege ich auch so eine dicke?
>> SAMIRA: So.
>> SALLY: Komm, du auch noch, Schatzele.
Oh!
Wir haben Eis gemacht!
Ihr dürft gleich probieren!
>> ELA: Ist das schon fertig?
>> SALLY: Noch ein bisschen muss es abkühlen. Okay?
Kannst du dich gedulden?
>> ELA: Nein!
>> SALLY: Ich glaube schon.
>> ELA: Och!
>> SALLY: Du kannst ja schon mal Hände waschen.
Und zeig mir mal, was dir wehgetan hat.
[Musik]
Das Eis ist bereit.
Mädels, seid ihr bereit?
>> SAMIRA & GRETA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also dann schnappt euch eine Kugel Eis,
Fruchteis,
und probiert mal.
Es ist halt ein Eis, was man praktisch sofort servieren sollte.
Wir hatten es jetzt auch noch mal im Gefrierschrank,
damit es fester wird.
Aber ihr seht schon, es wird natürlich dann ziemlich fest.
Denn man mixt es,
es kommt ganz kurz ins Gefrierfach
und dann isst man es sofort.
>> SAMIRA: Gibst du mir bitte die Erdbeeren?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Au ja, die Mini-Erdbeeren!
Mmh!
So komplett ohne Emulgatoren,
ohne Konservierungsstoffe,
ohne Farbstoffe,
ohne künstlichen Zucker,
einfach ein leckeres Fruchteis.
Wie findet ihr es?
>> GRETA: Gut.
>> SALLY: Gut?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mit den kleinen Mini-Erdbeeren und Himbeeren.
>> SAMIRA: Ein paar Streusel drauf.
>> SALLY: Oh! Sehr schön!
Okay, da hätten wir wieder den Zucker.
Aber ist okay.
Mmh!
Solltet ihr auf jeden Fall mal ausprobieren.
>> SAMIRA: Gut.
>> SALLY: Und vor allem könnt ihr die Farbe
definieren.
Also wir haben ja Heidelbeeren auch mit drin.
Das heißt, es ist ein ein bisschen dunkleres Eis.
Wenn ihr nur Himbeeren verwendet,
ist es ein bisschen pink.
Bei Erdbeeren ist es rosa.
Bei Kirschen ist es weinrot
>> JOSH: Oder mit Wein.
>> SALLY: – kirschrot.
Also richtig, richtig gut!
Probiert es gerne mal aus.
Postet euer Foto von eurem Eis.
Und dann sehen wir uns wieder beim nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
Und Kinder sind begeistert.
Und die Ela ist wahrscheinlich draußen
und spielt mit dem Wasser.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Dann kriegt sie jetzt noch eine Kugel Eis.
Tschüss!
Kommt ihr mit?
[Musik]
Wie schmeckt das Eis, Ela?
>> ELA: Gut.
Mama kocht einfach das beste Eis!
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> SAMIRA: Du filmst mich sogar noch!
[Musik]